hey everyone today let's talk about
hybrid cloud
now by the book it refers to a cloud
computing architecture
with two or more environments consisting
of public and private clouds
on premises and these days even edge
environments
but without the right strategy hybrid
cloud can actually pose a number of
challenges
now today we're going to go through an
example to lay out some of those
advantages and disadvantages
of a fictional distribution company
that started to undergo that hybrid
cloud transformation process
now we're going to start with what they
have kind of on premise
now right off the bat let's start with
this legacy application that they've got
now this is an application that enables
their users to get
shipment and tracking information and it
continues to work so they don't really
have a good reason to modernize it
although it is kind of running on some
legacy old school let's say java ee
based monolithic architecture
in addition they've also got some
customer data that's running on premise
now this is one of the key advantages of
hybrid cloud
is it lets you run workloads where you
need them
so in this particular case to comply
with gdpr
or maybe some other regulations they
need to keep that data on premise
which is actually a pretty cool
advantage of hybrid cloud that they can
continue to do that
now they've also got some hr software
running on premise we're going to call
this
bpms or business process management
software
and this is going to allow their
customers to do or rather their
workforce to do things like
requesting time off or maybe
you know doing some purchase work orders
that kind of thing
so that's what they've got on prem now
we mentioned that they've started the
hybrid cloud transformation
uh they started to take advantage of
cloud native so let's see what they've
done
in the public cloud now we've distilled
the cloud into kind of three major
categories in the past
so infrastructure as a service platform
as a service and software as a service
now let's start with paths and what
they've done here is they've taken
advantage of a kubernetes or
container-based environment
maybe even something like managed
openshift running in the cloud to create
a new version of the same application we
talked about before
the one one that works for mobile users
so mobile
backend as well as a database there that
kind of works
for mobile users to be able to get
tracking and shipment information but
this led to an increased cost and
support
to maintain all those users so they
started to take advantage of another
service available in the cloud
so here's where sas comes in they took a
chat bot
and they built it into that application
and that enables them to offset some of
that increased support costs
in addition let's say they're also using
some of the sas capabilities for iot
for their delivery drivers maybe in
their warehouses
their distribution centers that kind of
thing so iot is helping you know track
the goods and
maybe making sure they're temperature
controlled that kind of thing
and finally for is here's an environment
that i think kind of
benefits from lift and shift so some of
that business
process management software that they've
got running on prem maybe they've
migrated some of that software
over to the cloud and i think that's an
excellent opportunity to start taking
advantage of is
is by kind of doing that lift and shift
taking advantage of some of that
software and moving it there
maybe they're also running some cms
systems like wordpress for
content management and they're running
that as software
on some vms that are made available
through the ias capabilities in the
cloud
now those two environments are
integrated together because you know
they've got some shared data
uh obviously the web interface and the
mobile backend were probably using a
similar
data source finally they've also got
edge environments so these are going to
be things like
distribution centers they're called edge
environments because they're at the edge
they're
where data is being created and these
distribution centers
basically enable the customer to do
things like
kind of run workloads right where the
data is being created
so maybe something like kubernetes or
again open shift a distribution of
kubernetes
to manage uh the the edge workloads
where data is really being created
and those are obviously going to be
integrated to the on-premise and cloud
environments
to share data about shipments so their
users are getting the latest and
greatest information
about you know where that shipment is so
this is where the
the company is today and they've run
into a number of challenges
so number one they have increased
complexity
so as they've gone from on-premise to
the cloud and all these engine
environments now they have
kind of an increased number of
environments so their ops teams have to
maintain that
in addition they need a way to port
assets from one environment to another
so so far they haven't necessarily run
into any issues
but they're starting to build a chat bot
into the mobile backend and say hey
maybe we should start taking advantage
of that
on our web application as well and
they're finding they're not able to
easily do that their devops teams are
struggling
because their assets aren't quite
portable maybe they have multiple
vendors they're working with
there isn't that consistency and the
last concern i'll raise is security
more environments higher surface area of
attack their security team has to kind
of invest more resources to help
maintain these solutions
so there is a solution to all of this
and it's taking on a unified
and open hybrid cloud approach and
that's going to start at the
infrastructure layer
that we've already talked about a little
bit so that infrastructure layer
is going to be things like the
on-premise environment on-premises
environment
it's going to be public and private
cloud environments as well as edge
locations but here's where the key piece
kind of starts to
kind of work out so at the foundational
layer
they need to start building some
standardization so here's where they can
start
building in a consistent operating
system so something like
linux or rel or red hat enterprise linux
is going to help here because their
developers can work against a single
operating system across these multiple
environments
and i mentioned rel because that brings
me to my next point here
the platform layer
and here's where they're going to be
running something like kubernetes
kubernetes is great because it gives you
that consistent container based
environment
that works in any kind of location on
premise edge the cloud
but you can even take it a step further
with openshift container platform
which is going to give you that
enterprise supported approach to
containers
and again it's great because it runs
anywhere
finally the key to all of this is
the solutions so this consistency
and standardization enables customers to
focus on standardized solutions across
the board
so this can be things like the apps that
they're developing
or the data that they need to manage or
even security solutions
that they're building across the board
and this is just scratching the surface
there's other use cases here that i'm
not even
diving into things like integration
managing these multiple cloud
environments automation that kind of
thing
but this standardized layer and platform
enables them to focus on solutions that
work across the board
now this is going to lead to a number of
advantages now the number one thing
about hybrid cloud is that it needs to
be portable
that means your workloads need to be
able to move across environments
now we mentioned they've got a
monolithic legacy application
architecture on-prem
maybe they start pulling in openshift or
kubernetes on-premises
start refactoring into microservices and
cloud native based applications
and they start having containers for
that web interface application
now if they want to they can start
porting those assets to the cloud
and take advantage of the elasticity
there to scale up and down
on demand number two it's going to be
faster innovation now with that
portability their developers can now
think in a new way they can build once
and deploy anywhere
so that chatbot experience they built
for the mobile backend
they're going to be able to readily port
that to the on-premise experience to the
web user interface experience the legacy
app
if they modernize it to kind of
container-based architecture
so that's one of the key advantages
their developers are going to benefit
from
faster innovation reduce time to value
faster go to market by taking advantage
of the industry's best you know
devops and agile practices so that's a
key part about a hybrid cloud is
faster innovation and finally
as we mentioned before on the security
front with that standardized
layer of that open shift or kubernetes
that container-based environment across
the board
you're going to have consistency for
things like pushing out compliance
policies
to these multiple environments and
that's going to be critical here
to make sure you have that kind of
secure
and consistent approach across these
multiple environments
now in the interest of standardization
and standardization across the board and
having that kind of
consistent layer imagine if you could
handle all of these
layers right infrastructure foundation
and solutions all from a single
say public cloud environment that means
extending the public cloud
to not just on-premises environment but
maybe even other clouds
and the edge well that's when we're
starting to get into the concept of
distributed cloud
so i urge you to check out my video on
that
now with hybrid cloud it's going to be
paramount that you take a unified and
open approach
to truly set yourself up for success if
you enjoyed this video
have any questions be sure to drop a
like or comment below
stay tuned and follow us for more videos
like this in the future
thank you